demonstrations in the Guatemalan capital
the protests are against a move to
suspend presidential candidate Bernardo
Arevalo of the Progressive semiya Party
ahead of a contentious runoff election
scheduled for August 20th
according to a prosecutor from
Guatemala's Attorney General's office
the samedia party is under investigation
for alleged corruption
at the request of the special
prosecutor's office the seventh criminal
court ordered the suspension of the
legal status of the political party
semia movement
but then the country's Supreme electoral
Court stepped in announcing there was no
order made to officially suspend Arevalo
Instead The Electoral Court certified
the results of the June 25th general
election effectively overruling the
order from the attorney general
the runoff election will take place on
Sunday August 20 2023 with the
participation in rational Unity of Hope
with Sandra julita Torres Casanova as
presidential candidate and Romeo stuardo
Guerra running for vice president as
well as the semija movement with Cesar
Bernardo arevalo's presidential
candidate and Karina Larissa Carrera
Aguilar running for vice president
for his part Bernardo Arevalo has called
the allegations against his party
baseless and politically motivated
Arevalo has proven to be a surprisingly
popular candidate throughout the
campaign standing on an anti-corruption
platform he believes he's being targeted
by a corrupt government desperate to
remain in power
we are using all the legal tools of what
is left of our democracy in Guatemala
there is a lot at stake
on Thursday tensions Rose once more
after police raided the offices of the
Supreme electoral Court prompting
concerns from International observers
and in yet another twist Sandra Torres
presidential candidate from the uni
party announced a temporary pause to her
campaign in solidarity with her opponent
Bernardo Arevalo adding that her
campaign did not wish to take advantage
of the confusion surrounding the
elections
as uncertainty looms ahead of the August
20th runoff election many worry over the
threat of a brewing political crisis
which could put into question the future
of Guatemalan democracy
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera